what's going on guys welcome to a Python
mathematics and stock indicators
tutorial video in this video we're going
to be covering swing index and also
really the accumulative swing index so
my plan really is just to go A to Z with
this tutorial series here a tizzy and
indicators that is but it really the
cumulative swing index is just the
accumulation of a lot of swing indexes
so we're going to start off with swing
index explain what this is and then
start talking about how we're gonna
actually program this so the swing index
is developed by this Welles Wilder guy
the idea of it is to determine the
actual strength of the market and that
the trends of the market pretty much
it's used with futures and then you
wouldn't really necessarily have to but
the Bain here the main reason here is
you're using this limit move as part of
the equation here so that's pretty much
why it is reserved for futures and also
it's it's a long term kind of thing you
wouldn't necessarily use it intraday but
you can and probably what we're gonna do
here is intraday anyways so the
calculation or swing index is below
sometimes you'll see it as s I but I
think si is just kind of not good
especially when we're going through a
bunch of different indications
indicators so I usually call it's win or
SW I am now the calculation for this is
50 times c2 c1 plus 0.5 blah blah blah
blah yeah so what's all that mean this
is what it all means so is you know c4
close to one the ones is corresponds to
the prior day two is that day right and
then you know you've got basically this
entire equation the other things to keep
in mind is R has two steps to the
calculation here first you want to
figure out which is the biggest of you
know these three here and then if the
first one is the biggest then R equals
this calculation if the second is the
largest an hour equals this calculation
and so on
then k k is the largest period of either
h2 right so the high of today - the
close of yesterday or the low of today -
the close of yesterday which other which
either one that is the largest and
finally the output here it the output is
going to range from anything from a
negative 100 to 100 and the output is
either if it's positive that's a
positive signal the signal is positive
and it's negative its negative and the
actual you know changing signal appears
when the zero line is crossed so either
from a negative to a positive and so on
so that's what it is so as you can see
there's a few steps let's go back to the
steps here there's a few steps to the
calculation of this process first you
would want to obviously figure out what
R is actually equal to and what K is
actually equal to also L is equal to the
limit move right and if you're not
familiar with limit move is if you're
not interested in futures the limit move
is basically the most that future can
actually move so they set limits so it
can't move any more than X right so for
example gold would be $75 silver 50
cents and so on and so anyway so this is
the equation so we have a few different
steps to this equation so it's not maybe
as simple of some of these other
equations will end up being but at the
end of the day it's really quite simple
to do with in Python so that's what
we're gonna be doing in the next video
is breaking this equation down building
it up in Python and then we'll actually
graph the accumulation of the swing
index with that charting application
that I showed you guys again if you
don't have it you can just download it
off my website so anyways that's
interesting to you guys stay tuned to
the next video as always thanks for
watching